[Music]
in the slightly maybe starting to get
tedious and ever ongoing saga of jake
paul and tommy fury yeah are they
finally gonna fight or what nah that's
pulled out has just offered tommy fury
five hundred thousand dollars to fight
him in the uk next month oh tommy if you
read it uh jake paul offered tommy fury
he's not gonna come to your house like
additional half a million yeah just show
up so basically just to catch everybody
up uh tommy fury put on twitter
uh and he says uh i'm gutted and
disappointed in regards to the issues i
have faced with entry into the usa this
is something that myself or my team
could have never anticipated happening
this situation has been left with my
lawyers as being denied entry to a
country is obviously a very serious
issue and it needs to be subsequently
resolved
i am confident this fight will happen
when this issue gets resolved and we
come to a solution
i want to clarify
that i will uh i will fight in a neutral
country that both parties can enter this
can be anytime anyplace anywhere he goes
i'll just come to your house then so
then jake paul
gets back at him on twitter and says i'm
confident you are a scared little boy
who doesn't want to fight or understand
business good for promo i will pay you
500 000 to fight me in the uk i will do
it shortly after august 6. you accept
and he's like sorry i can't leave the
city i don't know
sorry i just made it to america you
didn't see i was working on it the whole
time
i took a boat i was on a boat i never
thought i would like jake paul it's just
just who he is as a person he seems kind
of like obnoxious
but throughout this whole narrative of
him and tommy fury of the guy who's a
youtuber right like a disney star
him challenging an actual boxer and a
boxer that's like seemingly [ __ ] his
bricks doesn't want to fight has all
he's playing all these games i'm like
holy [ __ ] i think i'm a jake paul fan
which is [ __ ] crazy yeah why is this
[ __ ] fighter ducking
a a youtuber and he's the brother to
like one of the greatest heavyweights of
all time logan paul
and i'm like [ __ ] that's [ __ ] crazy
you made him yeah i made the guy dude i
[ __ ] handed him everything
i'm like wow this is this guy's straight
ducking and then the part that really
earned my respect is after tommy pulled
out a legit heavyweight boxer stepped up
and jake paul didn't dodge it he goes
let's do it so the the actual card
that's happening
um do you remember his name i don't know
he was a big black dude right with
friends yeah and he but he's an actual
boxer you know
and then jake paul is actually going to
fight someone legit which is cool oh uh
haseem rahman junior was it supposed to
be uh tommy fury yeah and then it just
swapped with the actual boxer could it
get into the country yeah because tommy
was playing all these games
and he keeps offering more of what other
games because all i've heard so far is
he's got an immigration issue that's the
games he's been playing the whole time
oh like oh my my team can't get it i
can't fight without my team and then i
can't fight without my father or
whatever in my corner or like and then
jake and then jake goes i'll match you
he goes if your coach can't make it i
won't have a coach oh but this guy can't
make it then we'll just be two people in
a ring so he like he kept matching
whatever his like uh his bet was and
then um but all the way to the top paul
was trying to be accommodating and i
think he was a very accommodating which
is crazy i was like dude this full this
obnoxious dude is actually trying to
make it happen and i was just telling
bart like 10 minutes ago i just read
this article about john fury who is the
father of tyson fury and tommy fury came
out saying the reason why he pulled out
was because he wasn't training for the
past month
oh why would he burn out his old son
like that sometimes your parents are
boomers and you don't know what's going
on they're just answering your question
directly he's like what's twitter but
low key though john fury probably thinks
his son is a little [ __ ] dude
i bet the reason why
because there was some talk about how
you know john fury and tyson if you kind
of don't want tommy to take the fight
he's going to ruin the family name i bet
there's a little i bet if he goes down
to a paul that they'll probably see it
that way isn't he already ruining the
family family name but like not
dude he was on love island ruining the
past
not this kind of like yeah yeah it's not
a knockout meme yet right it's not like
a nate robinson thing i watched this
[ __ ] fall in love with this
trick named molly make crying his
eyeballs out ruining his family name
what do you guys think about uh the the
new guys fighting haseem ramen i don't
know anything about it
okay so i just looked him up this is an
american foreign professional boxer who
competed from 94 to 2014 he's a two-time
world heavyweight champion having held
the unified wbc ibf ibo and lineal
titles in 2001 so he's legit like [ __ ]
he first became known on the world stage
of 2001 when he scored an upset knockout
victory against lenox lewis to win the
unified heavyweight championship wait
jake paul fights in heavyweight division
i think he's going up he should be
he's been like that's the thing that i
had against him before he's fighting
smaller
guys because he's actually a pretty big
dude but now he's like actually fighting
people his weight how old is this young
man that he's fighting this young man
he's now 49. so that's going to be the
iffy part right but he beat lennox lewis
i know that's a big deal but then again
62 total fights yeah 50 wins 41 wins by
knockout nine losses two draws one no
contest way more hours did he beat lenox
lewis like like when lennox lewis was
like old
it was in 2001 and lewis avenged the
loss and regained his championship by
knocking out ramen in a rematch later
that year i guess it was a fair game all
right my bad my bad but that's going to
be something that people are going to
say right that he's old jake paul fights
his dude beats him oh he took a last
minute
he's a big guy
he's an older guy the jake paul haters
will never give him anything obviously
never i'm giving him and i was a jake
paul hanging out it's pretty crazy he
flipped me too
i was like dude [ __ ] this guy but i'm
like apologies i think jake paul is
fighting his son
[Music]
that sounds about right because it said
junior yeah oh yeah oh
when i clicked when i clicked this it
just went yeah he's fighting a 67 year
old man
i'm like i guess he still got it so
that's cool man
it might be kind of weird yeah son of
the former boxing heavyweight champion
no he's living in his glory dude uh uh
he was born in baltimore is a 12-1 uh as
a pro boxer with six knockouts
the eight-round ballot will be contested
at 200 pounds and will be broadcast on
showtime oh 200 is good so wait he's 31
he's fighting this guy and he wants to
fight tommy fury yes another monster he
wants to fight him and then a month
later fight time why why can't rich
people just [ __ ] enjoy their life
it's like you did it dude just
you can chill out now he's too young
ambitious he's too young how many
amateur fights does the sun have i'm not
sure let's see it just says 12-1 as a
pro boxer because the pro um record
doesn't really indicate the experience
level it's usually the amateur fights
let's see
like brandon lee for example he has like
20 something fights right
fury after over 100 amateur fights ramen
made his pro debut in 2017. yeah this
guy's a jail he started his career with
three wins via tko if his dad is a high
level boxer like that and he's you know
he's fighting out of baltimore this
guy's gonna be probably very legit as
somebody who doesn't know anything about
this sport
i'm still gonna comment on this um like
like i'm an expert yeah it's uh it's the
internet 100 amateur fights doesn't
sound that good
guaranteed i think it's the amateur part
right that's the finest like come on
sounds like a joke to me actually a
thousand amateurs yeah what's a hundred
participation awards worth what have you
had a hundred hardcore matches yeah that
sounds way better to me that sounds way
better yeah yeah 100 hardcore hardcore
per amateur professional but yeah jake
earned my respect because he's really
fighting a legit boxer someone his size
age
it's um and he's but he's ruining the
integrity of boxing man i don't get that
there's so much integrity in boxing
that's what's so stupid about this like
oh the honor of the sport i'm like we're
watching we're paying to watch two guys
beat the [ __ ] out of each other like oh
but the tradition ryan there's so much
tradition
but people give [ __ ] to jake paul but
jake paul has done a lot for the sport
of boxing like he actually no people
care it was boring as [ __ ] mayweather
ruined it yeah
but he's actually been co-promoting um
his like one of his i think his teammate
i guess you would say amanda serrano who
was a very high level like female boxer
and she fought this irish woman named
katie taylor who's like the
boxing female goat and they co-promoted
this this uh first ever female only
boxing match and it [ __ ] did really
good so uh you know like from fighter to
fighter though i can't i can't believe
we can stand here right now and you just
promote this youtuber coming into the
game and just [ __ ] it all up like
that dude like
i don't know man i thought you were
different nick but i think i think
you're a hybrid though i think didn't
this room do a little bit of that when
jake paul was coming up to promote jake
paul or barton joe maybe a little bit
some uh some uh paul brothers hatred
because
he's like
i was i was openly hating them yeah i
know yeah yeah but now he's open no what
i'm saying is i didn't do a little bit
of that a lot of guys like a lot of the
apologize right now i think it's kind of
so much
i'm in love now i never need to play
jake apologize anyways let me add fuel
to the spider apologist is good thank
you hey that was a good one he liked it
he liked it
i do want to add a little bit of fuel to
this fire
not long ago ramen and paul sparred
against one another and ramen was upset
by paul's antics and a video was
recently released showing that oh this
is fun what do you do just kick him in
the balls i'm just gonna play it from
this browser is that a did they tell is
that a fly for a sparring match no this
is the flyer for the august 6th date now
now it's no longer tommy fears like same
[ __ ] poster
that's pretty funny
where are we do i have volume here
i know
something you want to talk [ __ ]
[Music]
see i think that's where jake paul
really [ __ ] thrives dudes with
people's heads
this is jake paul's ig so he posted the
flyer he posted that clip so jake paul's
one who posted that clip online such a
good promoter in that same carousel he's
posting this madison square guardian
with his belt then he posts floyd mother
of mayweather had 44 amateur fights and
then went to the sixth pro fight
canelo had 46 amateur fights
uh right here jervan german german
gervante there you go six uh or 34
amateur fights then he goes to me one
amateur fight six pro fight 12-1 hassan
rahman jr heavyweight so he's just he's
he's talking [ __ ] what is what he's
really trying to show he's talking about
a lot of [ __ ] good [ __ ] real quick
yeah so what he's really trying to say
go back to the floyd mayweather one
the point that he's trying to make is uh
people like mayweather
on their sixth pro fight they ended
people's careers so he fought bobby so
you see how bobby's 19 and eight yeah
ended career in 1999. so what he's
saying is after six pro fights these
legends ended people's lives he's saying
he's gonna end that guy's life on top of
the fact he's saying that
these guys
these canelos girvanta floyd mayweather
they're fighting guys with really bad
records but his first fight his six pro
fight that jake paul is gonna have is
against a guy who is 12 and one can you
go anyway can you go back to that video
this is how i know to pick it back off
of what nick was talking about yesterday
with fighter talk this is how i know
that i'm not a fighter
you put yeah
let me get into this
[Music]
so this [ __ ] starts right you're at the
gym this [ __ ] starts
i know when someone
you want to talk no i'm
he's a big guy
he's stepping up dude this is gonna be a
good stop jake paul really might get
slept so there's actual stakes here but
also like
just i find it so funny when like the
fighter is just like oh this guy's
talking [ __ ] i'm like
yeah like what do you what are you doing
at practice ryan is that what happens
see this is why i don't like jake paul
yeah
he took the honor out of the fight there
it is
there it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you